génocide crime commis contre un peuple
un groupe national ethnique ou religieux
génocide arménien le premier de ce xxème
siècle durant cette période l'empiré
ottoman se réduit comme une peau de
chagrin le gouvernement jeune-turc mène
alors une intense politique de
purification et décide de régler
définitivement la question arménienne
sur les deux millions trois cent mille
arméniens vivant dans l'empiré ottoman
il y aura plus d'un million et demi de
morts
les rares rescapés
forme la diaspora
oui
arrivé en france en 1926
sa cure c'est avec ces temps le 24 avril
tu reçois des à notre ami me cherchais
toute ma famille il a mené chez lui 2 3
après yannick il est où beaucoup de vos
parents ont péri ce jour-là tous
on était dans notre famille si je compte
tout ça c'est plus que ce soit simple je
ne demande pas à dire pour atteindre à
1996 pour que le terme de génocide doit
employer par une fille glissions de
droits de l'homme inattendu a pris une
jolie sur un studio 1985 une résolution
du parlement européen reconnaissant sans
ambiguïté le génocide des arméniens pour
les ondes de matière couronne et
revendicatif noir s'agit des cas même si
l'on n'est qu'un premier pas et puis bon
c'est récupération des territoires
principalement 24 à vous
onze journées commémoration et
reconnaissance du jeu des nations
remporté par les derniers événements
pour attacher le choc pour la diaspora
j'allais difficile bientôt
c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
normal dans la mesure où on serait
d'abord il faut quand même bien pensé
que cink arménienne arménien dispersé
armée ni morceler le mont ararat
montagne mythique est symbolique est
toujours dur